[Music]
the sick
all
[Music]
in spain single
welcome welcome welcome been
elected president of the
association no Templar association to the
study of the medieval sword handle
of the cycle of 37 the period and  mail that there
is the horde of time the two
manufacture of the memorial time
third of them but it will not be for her as an
average that the son of yes 6
10 7 that when the quality of the evening I
said I gave her was superior to or less to
do  a sword and the curd toledo and
sifting through the usual from abroad as
revolt highness will see millennial snow the
mafia salween tangible
no magic son sensation
san marino seems to master expand
businesses with the palace formation when
we get a speaker six years
this and a suit to hold on to
prepare the misses to the one already
currently you are the only rock master and swords
and that was inside the thanks
of the rival torje and the series then
from the origin mucho tiemp  o and his sword
big enough they did a sprint and
so much to let in finds the memory
runs to the pad to other small organizations
of argentina for repairs music on
tour best sofia film on tour
for the inner by solari between the phobia man
[Music  ]
hand the manufacture of the
minimum important shootout if of the toreno jacquard
alessia who through the fita fair
has faith knows sock you will follow the despar
[Music]
we are talking with its
historical gremist builder and the association to
emulate it that series to a duel and
through  from the study of the treaties the
manuals of the sky 3 from the single building
at the end the diagnosis center was not practiced
and we are this protective will
compete with special gloves and caritas
protection I hope and we did not go to the
rate tenemos that with our
knowledge is enabled search
wheel steps a  the climate association
if then constitute any type however
the importance and the relationship that
these instrument holds with the trust  a ismu grande
taille mucho mysticism antonella raio
della spada
itn certain enchantment had it lures ps of the
first bishops of a me in love
[Music]
not even te morano
the first chapters on the way back
were written  now we try
to continue working with this type
of technique which is very special and
has ancient origins I
am doctor chiara squarcina I am
the person in charge of the murano glass museum
it was glass started in
murano around the year
1900 the techniques have
here you have refined techniques that
later spread throughout the
rest of Europe and the world
the master glassmaker has the art of glass
in his blood history has been written
[Music]
are marcello moretti are members
dell'arcole moretti then this is
a family business was born in 1911 the
founders are my grandfather with his other
brothers the represents the third
generation for the company is similar to
fiori signifi  about thousands of thousands of
flowers we create plates bowls
pendants necklaces earrings bracelets
rings all in mourinho glass then
this is a wildflower wand
is made by superimposing
different layers of glass is first
cut then these pieces are assembled and
then with the fusion is the
glass is an essential thing it gives
moral
and Murano glass
[Music]
my name is matteo tagliapietra and I am
a master glassmaker more in murano he
has been working with glass for
about 30 years
there is a vase that puts us in half '  now a
vase that can take even three
hours to do it
is a vase like the one I was doing
today you can start from the weight of one thousand
euros even 5,000 euros it depends that
is there is not much processing and then when I
see my finished product I
am  also satisfied but never
one hundred percent because he always wants to do
better I find on the brin defect a year
for glass is very important there is a
year is the  glass all those who
work glass around the world
that is their dreams come here to murano
see us who work our own work
a passion
[Music]
the class
often the bassano skills japan book
and cognitive strengths of  enrolled dark
wrote police jersey manner but
haitien family of active chickens de rosa
grassa uses the entourage of swiss
ankara exams in poor cellars if you know who
is talking about it is the floraisons helot a little
less badly that a median sac is created  and
sava we register dissatisfaction 33 the
crisis and the desire yes
yes but to extinguish in the olive ba
mandate of satisfaction 2 the thing in the
end of life
in the eyes that again on stage
kanit and only to do 7 that external
leave each other after I made it  for
reasoning daily effects hand
italy look a penny wise android
giovacchini damage from fiscal port the
damages caused peak with santa
originate daily as 12 ditches saints
wolf hips ruud extreme a  ggiungerei
that comes a few grams to describe
taranto from a senator of pasta from tampa
step of the meals of b2 never emerged
that he cares about the kings cras fire film
high school and the state
[Music]
the naples
had left me  out the years to
come
[Music]
an appeal that of a cynicism I found a
steadfast that left that he was sad
jesus this mutual league of his said
stability plan basilisks are crates to
whom I have taken in talk shows mode
a guy with a fuchsia l  'man the fire
whose mechanics and delicacy
in class g apple its physiological and non-
cosmar factors that are ready yes the
mushrooms the reason for all this many
curious and from the things we have to do it
the history of smoking decided without immediately
[Music  ]
magnificent
[Music
] Italy that the duvet
is therefore very comfortable from the benches
illustrates how youtube if right now and then it
reads slaps damion d'ora the defenses
of world fashion went to video and to
its design and ch  the six that if it or
on the orders and delicate as the
vuitton obsessions of the tomica putting
the most finger
prato 19 dreamed what I believe but a
house goes there the apology the society and not
having to lorido more primacy and processes
than the former black of the mood  more duration a
calm
switching the free under more cases semo
an easter the stop dear and fieschi
are clinic usa voto suisse after two
races doctor was ward I already saw
jackson the mood for automax horn
yesterday
[Music]
some the hall and did not mention  the
salvo ferdi network and the chance of the
network that hut for equal conditions and prizes
nobel josè scanu for everything good
from the chasm on forgiveness for gifts
mou a salina brought capital of the
company
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome already
pietrasanta
my name is paolo carli we are located
exactly on the highest mountain in the
heart in a mountain entirely rich
in marley in this quarry we have been extracting marble
for 500 years here we extract the ma  most
valuable rmi that
many architectural and
artistic works are used in the world but this is a
very ancient story
this mountain was mainly
discovered by michelangelo the golden age
of pietrasanta sculpture was
certainly born after the presence of
michelangelo the mining activities began
which also  pietrasanta and finds
an important role in
particularly classical and religious
sculpture our extractive quantities are about
20 thousand tons per year
the best blocks are currently
selected we manage to have
large blocks blocks of
uniformity without breakage
are subsequently transferred to
our laboratory warehouse
oak wood to be subsequently
worked in varied forms that
include architecture design card
from the mountain and from the house that was born the
first sculpture
my name is massimo galleni and I am
a craftsman sculptor pietrasanta is
known throughout the world explains the
work  classical ropes
but of these decades he has now
known that many important artists
have produced their lore or their
stone works made in the
various oratory of mine and the other we create
classic works classic copies religious copies
or in fact we work  for artists
then we do the works and the artists
create there are the various workers
then modeler finisher sculptors
then do the anatomies and adorned
st
I'm renzo Maggi I'm a sculptor and
painter so to learn what
I put I was seven now in 74 in short  about
sixty years and tomorrow morning when
I come back so don't talk about different things yet
practically marble to my life
because in this area you eat you
eat marble
I do the writings myself the pen
sole mondello I make models in
I believe but generally  I work live
in marble, I draw it on the stone and then
I go directly
I get help from some
innovations such as discs  diamonds but in
general and I would prefer and I prefer to
work with tools at
once I do not appreciate they are works that
can be worth about thousand and 50 thousand
but I think so as I am very modest
thinks ps the great sculptor of the world
who are paying I always say  to
say when I die on the grave it takes
a piece of energy wherever I turn there is a
wizard pietrasanta I mean that without
the marble no one would know it
[Music]
[Applause]
to guys mike brown panait I hope they
were ceca no tav e spreads  6 race
place for the lenk